The dog ate my homework.
Did you guys will understand what that means.
We're going to have to postpone the rapid Chunski case.
I got back from Washington late last night and,
um,
got the officer's morning and the SOM server was down.
I actually did some of the filming and visited their offices in Warsaw three
years ago.
Um,
and I would like to divert us a little bit today.
Uh,
I want to talk briefly about what I've been doing in Washington and how it
relates to what we've been doing here.
And then you'll remember some weeks ago before the midterm,
we had a soft sketch,
soft scheduled to do the mores business plan.
And I brought with me today to distinguished colleagues who are going to help
us,
uh,
do,
understand the mortgage business plan as a challenge.
Uh,
Chris Guttman,
uh,
immediately to my right is the president of the Mores Board of governors and a,
a,
an eye iconic figure at Yale.
Uh,
he has been the owner of how many dapper Dans,
handsome,
handsome dance,
pardon me,
for and including the incumbent
and Jonathan Ingham.
And now immediately to my right is a former president of the Yale Club of New
York,
Yale College class of six,
four,
six,
five
a and has been one of the instrumental players in the more he's business plan.
Um,
before I get to that,
I want to want to talk a little about Washington.
I'd been down there,
uh,
working,
for a company,
but it has brought me into contact with staff in the Senate and the house.
And I thought I'd share a little of the texture of that with you because it
relates
to capitalism in,
or at least two American capitalism in a,
in an interesting way.
Um,
as you know,
Saturday night at quarter to midnight,
the House of Representatives passed a version of the healthcare reform bill by
the margin of two 20,
Yay,
15 nay.
The first thing remarkable about that number is it adds up to 435.
Very few bills add up to four 35.
This one was one where being absent would be the sort of a,
a fence which could cost you your seat in Congress because the intensity is at
high.
Uh,
the other feature of it or a,
and I read,
I can't claim to have read more than about 20% of the bill.
Um,
but the stunning,
the stunning feature of it is that the fingerprints of lobbyists are all over it
in a,
in a degree that
is just,
it was to me a pretty disturbing [inaudible].
I'm,
I'm reasonably cynical about how the world works,
but the number of cases where,
um,
the bill be going along talking about one thing and then there'll be a
paragraph,
it will be labeled section one,
seven,
five,
three,
and it will require the services of licensed podiatrists
or it will require,
uh,
a funding grant to a certain category of health providers in a region of several
western states.
It's just pockmarked with very intense lobbying.
And then when you talk to the staffs of the two parties,
you get two very different kinds of talk.
MMM.
Let's leave my politics out of this.
Uh,
which side do you think would sound more coherent right now?
The Republicans or the Democrats talking about the healthcare bill?
We got,
have I got a mic I can hand somebody.
Thanks.
Lastly,
who wants to take a shot at that one?
Uh,
I would guess the Republicans,
since they haven't had to,
had,
they haven't had to have made concessions to numerous special interests to get
the bill passed or repick.
You nailed it.
Are you a political science major?
Yes.
Good for you.
Uh,
in Washington this year,
a two point $9 billion,
repeat that number.
Two point $9 billion was spent on lobbying the federal government
and uh,
well compared to the cost of the healthcare bill,
that doesn't sound like much.
It's an awful lot of lobbyists and the majority party on a bill like this is,
uh,
well how many,
let's suppose they did it as follows.
Obama brings in
50 men and women from Harvard,
Yale,
Berkeley,
Michigan,
uh,
Texas and so on.
And they spend 30 days working,
uh,
on the best possible bill to get the most bang for the buck,
for the general public in a new health care plan.
And then he puts it on bloke and sends it up to the CAP,
sends it over to Capitol Hill,
bought how many boats,
if it were really well done,
do you suppose it would gap?
Maybe we're going to take a guess at that.
We have historical experience.
This is what the Clintons did right nearly two decades ago and it got shot full
of holes immediately.
Right?
There was just virtue.
There was virtually no support for it because all the defensive interest groups,
uh,
staked out their ground,
no concessions or very few concessions were made and it just sank.
I does anybody remember how the Obama people handle this piece of legislation?
What did they say to the speaker of the house?
Nancy Pelosi?
Anybody?
You guys read newspapers?
Tom,
you,
do you have any memory though?
Yeah.
Alright.
He more or less,
I gave some broad outlines of principles for the building and said you do it
right handed the whole thing over to the legislature.
Okay.
So he handed the thing to the House of Representatives and the lobbying process,
uh,
became very intense.
Andy,
it is a,
uh,
an incredibly intricate set of not most,
most of it.
Uh,
an awful lot of it is like the earmarks for a bridge in Alaska,
but it's usually not a bridge in Alaska.
It is a podiatrist in an office spread all the way across the country.
And,
um,
I really do believe in markets and there is so much in this bill that would not
meet market test.
Right.
If you said we're going to require the service of podiatrists in a certain
certain aspect of it and you ask yourself,
what would people sign up for that if it were not required by law.
And in an awful lot of cases,
the answer is yes,
of course some would sign up for it,
but the amount spent would be billions less than if you do it this way.
No,
you all can have ma,
I voted for President Obama and I'm,
uh,
deeply supportive of his and other people's goals for the country.
But this bill,
um,
I can't,
I really can't stand up for it.
Um,
anybody want to take the affirmative about why it is?
We've just got to get this done.
I promise to be polite.
Okay.
Well we'll go from something easy to something more difficult.
Morrie's is,
okay.
Let's first of all find out how many of you have ever set foot in Maurice.
Wow.
So we have a whole room full of experts.
Um,
and would somebody like to recap what they think the last year or two of Maurice
Existence look like?
This could be fun.
Go for it.
There was like a struggle to be much more inclusive.
So they were all of these promotions.
So you could get a Morrie's membership for $10.
It could come in and get $10 off.
You're like meal and um,
my friends and I totally made you sit back cause we'd like eating everywhere at
Yale,
around yell.
Um,
so we did go a few times.
but we never got to,
I don't think we ever got really got him worries membership.
Things fell through and then we never really heard about it.
Yeah.
Okay.
It closed on the 19th of December.
Do you want your money back?
No.
Okay.
You don't have
anybody want to want to want to say anything about what they think the place was
like from a member or customer point of view over the,
over the last couple of years.
Any complaint we have complaint,
where did I see a hand here?
Here's one back here.
The food,
the food and how was the service?
Meza.
Mass.
Yep.
Um,
Maurice lost a lot of money in the last two and a half years.
It operated,
um,
roughly speaking
$1,000 a day.
And uh,
Chris Suffocate,
Chris Jackman here became its president,
uh,
after,
the disaster was revealed and has been working with a group of us to bring it
back.
And I thought I would
start with
uh,
Chris
and just get him to reflect for a minute on what the task looks like and what we
hope to accomplish.
And then,
then we'll talk to Jonathan and,
and then I'll come back with a summary of the,
of the business plan.
Well,
let me start by saying that the,
how's this work?
Push it off or
it works.
Just that
thing.
Yeah.
Talk like this
first thing I did before I became president or
I can play
with the clothes,
the place,
everybody,
one person whose name is Robin foam
rubber
and then we had a lay off all of us that
we were going to run out of money in the middle of January.
We closed on the 19th of December.
And actually this was a good thing because you said
do you have in the quality of the food and
we were not succeeding in that regard at all.
I think I want to be reopened.
It's going to be at a place where you guys are reaching out to the students.
If you want to pretend that box back.
I think I did after that was the job to work in addition to great guy.
He was also a former web and as I think most of you know,
very important
along with a lot of other
faculty is a big part of,
we
raise money to not only make capital improvements to the Clo that it was pretty
rundown,
but structural improvements.
Um,
it goes to the wiring all the way to getting working fireplaces.
On a couple of the rooms and the cost to do what we hope to do is going to be
something in the neighborhood of two point $9 million.
Um,
we're,
we're well along the way to do that and I hope to have good news about the fact
that we've reached our goal.
You ready to talk to and can open and we're not going to sign it and longterm
contracts with electricians or plumbers or contractors until we know we'll be
able to see the job all the way,
bro.
It's been fun.
There's an awful lot of Mris is the largest private club in the world because in
the old days there were,
you're a lifetime and it cost
15 bucks to join from life.
And so we have 14,000 I probably 13,000 members now,
many of whom we don't hear from.
But there's an awful lot of loyalty and a positive sentiment about the club and
we're very confident that this is going to happen and I'll just let Tom weigh in
or Doug or
probably don't need it.
Yeah.
Um,
why Morris and why Morrie's as an association as opposed to an adjunct door,
some form of,
uh,
of an open house,
being run by Yale.
Um,
let's back up a little bit.
10 minutes ago Doug asked me is come in and share some of my,
my thoughts about more ease with you.
And,
um,
uh,
so this is,
I'm,
I'm talking as I'm thinking,
um,
and I'm going to try and relate it to,
the purpose of this class,
which is capitalism.
First of all,
there's something wrong.
Did we do that?
Why Morrie's?
I came back to the Yale bowl about five or so years ago when I was watching the
Harvard game and I was sitting with some of my Harvard friends and,
and uh,
uh,
about halfway through the game I wasn't having any fun.
I'm going to go back to new haven and a just hang out in new haven who was going
on.
I couldn't find a door that was unlocked in the entire town of new haven.
And I'm thinking to myself,
where do you like me?
Go on a heartbeat weekend or any other kind of weekend,
or when I want to show up in town,
there's no place.
And I wasn't a member of Morrie's before I got involved with this,
because back when I was your age plus two or three years,
I didn't have the 25 bucks to,
or at least I didn't think it was a good expenditure,
$25 for lifetime memberships.
So I kind of ignored it.
And then I started going back,
uh,
with a,
with alumni group and we would sing on occasional Morrie's Mondays when the
whips were somewhere else.
And it occurred to me that this was,
uh,
a place that
deserves to be alive.
But as I looked around and saw this place,
um,
it clearly you didn't reflect the needs of the marketplace.
It was basically a place where old guidance ago and,
uh,
have meals occasionally.
Um,
I didn't see any students there.
He didn't,
there was no,
uh,
vibrancy,
no,
no relevance to the place.
And,
uh,
so then I got because of these guys and the whole concept of what Morrie's
should be,
uh,
became crystallized my thinking.
Um,
it belongs because it represents a a hundred,
150 years of experience.
So all the pictures up there,
all conditions,
cops,
everybody has their own particular memories about it.
But collectively it is an important part of I think the Yale experience.
And I think sadly,
um,
it's hasn't been an important part of your collective experience.
Um,
I think if you do a survey among graduate students,
for instance,
85,
90% of them won't even,
uh,
or,
or never thought that they were eligible for membership in Morrie's.
Uh,
so I think what we were trying to do here is to preserve the memorable aspects
of more easy icon,
a iconic nature of the place,
but also to open it up and make it a,
a welcoming institution for the student body,
both graduate and undergraduate.
And by that I mean having expanding things like singing group nights,
doing things which we found to be successful at the Yale Club in New York,
which was to have poetry readings,
discussions that novels,
uh,
you kind of bought.
We want to be open to,
um,
uh,
the student body to be able to say,
come on in and let's discuss this here.
And then of course we hope that that sort of activity will spill over and
accrued if some selling drinks and food and stuff.
Terrific.
But basically,
let me just finish one thing.
It belongs run by market forces,
not by Yale.
The alumni,
the rose alumni house is useless as far as most graduates go.
And a Maurice,
which would be run by Yale I think would similarly not be relevant.
I believe in active welded on restaurant bar lounge,
which is responsive to the needs of the student body is the way to go.
And that's where I think we're trying to come out on this day.
Okay.
Um,
now let's talk business.
A Morrie's in its last year of operation did about $900,000 of bar and
restaurant business.
And when I say bar and restaurant,
uh,
you may be confused by the first word where it's the bar at Morrie's.
There is not
right.
It's founded on drinking songs and it has no bar kind of odd.
Uh,
it is all about Yale and only percent of Yale's enrolled students belong to it.
Um,
it is a
business with an absolutely natural market all its own.
Uh,
Steven Blumenfeld who's a junior in the college was in this course a year ago
when I got started on this and he said,
why don't we do a survey?
So he did a survey monkey instrument and got 600 student answers.
And the most interesting thing about it was that something over 200 of the 600
thought that they were ineligible to join Morrie's.
They thought it was somehow for all different reasons,
but a third of our market just thought can't go there.
Um,
so that's kind of an issue.
Well the,
the,
uh,
also in the background university has done some focus groups over the last five
years looking for a what students and the larger Yale community won in the
Broadway block,
part of the unit,
part of part of town.
What do you think comes up?
Number one
bar and a specific kind of bar,
a sports bar.
And uh,
what we're going to do is,
and the back of the building facing away from York steet street toward the
bookstore toward Morse and stiles toward the retail block,
we're going to put a bar that will have a walkway and an indoor walkway into the
main building.
And we will be a kind of,
um,
it'll have characteristic Morrie's memorabilia and a Yale atmosphere to it.
But there will be plasmas and you can watch,
you know,
even some such,
uh,
below the salt institutions as Michigan and the University of Southern
California and so on,
uh,
on a plasma screen,
the,
um,
and that slot into the,
the basic bottom line goal.
Uh,
Maurice did $900,000 in business.
You had had,
uh,
roughly a million and a half and expenses.
So last year you do the math.
The average labor cost embodied in each meal served was $31 and 50 cents.
Cogitate that for a second.
I didn't say anything about the cost of the food.
Heat,
electricity,
Labor,
Labor 31 50.
Yes.
I remember you mentioned in class earlier this year that it was because of the
labor unions.
And so is that still a problem?
MMM.
One of the reasons we didn't do this a few weeks ago is that I can't give a give
a straight answered every question.
And that's one of the questions,
which is very much up in the air.
Uh,
it,
if I said it was because of the union,
I misspoke.
The union is my assessment is that the problems for the union,
we're about a quarter to a third of what was wrong.
And Chris,
you know,
mostly when,
when people say we've got a terrible labor problem,
first question you have to ask is don't you maybe have a terrible management
problem and uh,
Maurice had both and often the trouble,
the,
the contract was onerous.
There's no question,
um,
uh,
tight work rules,
benefits a comparable to General Motors.
Um,
it was,
it was a bad contract,
but,
uh,
we have a very cooperative relationship with unite here and local to 17,
and we're working on a constructive agreement that will include all kinds of
things you don't usually see in labor contracts.
This is me speaking,
not an official statement.
It is my hope that it will include a uh,
individual incentive story where if people work hard and help us produce
profits,
they'll share in them beyond their wages.
Um,
and I actually think we might get to that.
I have no,
no,
nothing to announce,
but just an aspiration.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we eventually come up with a business plan and Maurice has to go from 900,000 in
business to 1,000,009,
uh,
and much under 1,000,009.
Uh,
it isn't going to work.
So,
uh,
then you ask yourself,
how many restaurants in new haven make 1,000,009 a year in gross revenue?
Anybody got a guess?
They're Mbas in the room.
You guys are good at guessing
Igor,
will they have,
how many restaurants make a million?
Nine a year gross in,
in new haven.
Okay.
Zero.
You're not too far off.
Richard,
will you have a handful?
You nailed it too is the answer.
There are exactly two such restaurants and they're both,
uh,
on the edge of the campus and therefore potentially competitors to Maurice.
Can you name them?
No.
Union league.
Say Again?
I think I heard the right answer.
Zinc.
Yeah.
And those are guests.
Those are guesses on my part there rather well educated guesses.
It's not as if these restaurants gave me their books.
Um,
but they're my good gay there.
My guesses.
So that's the competitive standard.
Um,
Borys what drives the business?
What's the first driver you have to think about?
Well,
the,
we all know it has to do with food,
drink service,
quality of experience in every way.
MMM.
But why don't more people walk through the door?
Well,
partly because all those things are not very good,
but partly because they don't think they're invited
and because they don't think they're invited,
it never occurs to them to come.
Now what
if you were going to,
let's name a demographic by how old they are,
how much money they make,
um,
and where they live.
Who should we think of as the people who,
who can make more ease into,
excuse me,
a one point $9 million business.
Okay.
How about a Yale Alumni living in California?
Hands up for that.
Okay,
so that's not so that the fact that Yale has 160,000 living alumni and that the
vast majority of them have handsome incomes.
Okay.
Does that solve our problem or not?
Not.
Okay.
Is there a subset that might help solve our problem?
Yes.
Okay,
good.
It's a 30 mile radius,
right?
And there,
there are about 7,800 yellow alumni in a 30 mile radius.
Uh,
and we're now getting almost none of them.
Can you think of another market segment that you might want to pay attention to?
It's already been mentioned.
Yeah,
I'm holding up a mirror.
It's you
now.
Um,
let's start.
May I presume to start with you?
Can I have one of these mics?
Uh,
this is a sales call.
Okay.
I'd like you to join Morrie's.
What is that?
How much do I have to pay a,
you have to pay $15.
What year are you?
I'm a senior.
You're a senior.
Okay.
Well you're not going to get the best deal because the price is for the duration
of your years at Yale as a student.
The price is $15 and we're going to give you a $10 food and drink credit.
Are you 21?
Yeah.
Okay,
so a $10 drink and food credit.
Um,
so the net cost to you,
if you liked either drink or eat,
and we have good stuff is $5
I picked my nose.
Yeah.
Five.
Now you're going to have to write a check for 15 but you'll spike one of those
rebate coupons.
You know,
you got to do it or not.
I'd have to,
it depends on other people I know are going to do it.
Okay.
That's a really good answer,
right?
It depends on if other people I know are going to do it.
And,
um,
just how I think you're exactly right.
But tell me,
tell me how you got what,
what are you thinking?
Um,
well,
I've never been to Morrie's before and I don't want to just go and sit by myself
with nothing.
No one else I know is going to be there.
Okay.
That's absolutely the right answer,
right?
Because,
uh,
restaurants and clubs are so called network good.
And the value of going by yourself and sitting in the corner is not very hot.
Right.
It's meant to be friendly.
Okay.
So there's,
there's a huge insight there.
Let me try a couple more people.
Um,
Jennifer,
how about you?
I,
this was sales part sales call.
You already know the price.
All right.
Well,
I'd want to know what kind of food they serve because if I have,
if I'm a picky eater,
maybe I wouldn't even enjoy going there because I'm not 21 yet.
Okay.
You're not 21.
Are you a picky eater?
Uh,
for these purposes?
Yes.
Today.
Okay.
And w what are,
what are you,
where are your criteria?
Uh,
let's say I'm a Vegan,
would I eat
well?
So the,
the,
the three quarter pound hamburger that we plan to serve is not going to do it
for you.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you're going to want to have you don't insist,
I insist that we serve only vegan food.
No,
but I want to know that if I go there,
I will enjoy my experience.
So if you have the options that I would eat.
Okay.
So vegan options and uh,
we're,
we're going to be open a lot.
Used to be,
we roping 39 hours a week,
we're going to be open 65 and a half hours a week.
And a lot of that extra time is pub time where the restaurant will be closed,
but the pub will be open and the ideas come in and meet your friends for a drink
and have a big Vegan Burger.
How are we getting anywhere with you on that?
With Vegan Burger or net?
Ah,
yeah.
And you know,
most things served at a bar are Vegan,
so I think I would,
sure.
Okay.
So you're excited.
You're,
did you sign up or not?
Still in doubt.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
let's go right here.
MMM.
So 15 bucks,
minus 10.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I actually,
I thoroughly enjoyed going even before the,
uh,
before it shut down.
But,
um,
even I never see,
I never went to it's,
he was the thing though.
We,
we always went for,
for cops to the group of friends or something along those lines.
So I'm definitely attracted by the car.
And do you actually like cups?
Um,
I,
it was more just sort of the,
the experience,
which is what was being discussed.
I actually think there's this peculiar thing about cops.
I know lots of people who do cups and don't like them
and it's what they're doing and it's your point.
It's the social thing.
It's with your friends that Chris,
can you claim to like cops?
Um,
probably not
quite right.
Yeah,
it is the experience.
Jonathan,
I think I remember that.
You don't much care farm
and I liked to drink.
Yeah.
We have that in common.
All three of us.
Yep.
Uh,
so,
uh,
it's a pretty diverse student market,
but,
uh,
it turns out that the students are the drivers,
the biggest driver for the whole thing.
And the reason is that the ambiance of the place is geriatric,
right?
And Geriatric is boring.
Uh,
for example,
I got my [inaudible] mother to move into an assisted living home a year ago,
and she said,
promise me you'll get me out of here after a year if I hate it.
And after a year,
she said,
I hate being around these old people.
Get me out of here and she's out.
Um,
and so we've got to get you involved to get other people involved.
Now,
uh,
the faculty are also the term turns out the faculty are the biggest spenders on
a per capita basis at Morrie's.
It's moving a piano,
I guess.
Uh,
but we're still way short of enough.
What I've talked about now so far is about enough to do a million,
1,000,001,
1,000,002.
Where else are we going to go looking for customers?
Anybody got a thought in the back?
That's that.
Let me get you the mic.
Tourists and visitors.
New Haven.
Okay.
Um,
tourists and visitors.
What do you think guys?
John,
do you think that'll work or not?
Yeah.
The trouble with that is that we're a club now.
It could be the people who have reciprocal agreements with the Morrie's club.
And there are how many clubs like that right now,
there's only,
but they're going to be several Rio.
Okay.
Uh,
we,
our business plan counts on no business from tourists.
Uh,
anybody else got a thought?
Making members renew membership annually.
So even if they are not actually coming into the restaurant,
they still pay the membership fee.
Okay.
Turns out that the membership dues are,
are they're a nice little add on,
but they're there in the neighborhood of the last couple hundred thousand
dollars.
Uh,
you know,
and that's not chicken feed for us,
but it's not foundational.
Uh,
in the back,
one of the barriers for Maurice was the perception of exclusivity and you open
up membership to the larger Yale Community broadly defined,
that would open up new revenue streams.
So not just the students,
but faculty and staff as well.
Okay.
That's huge.
Uh,
first of all,
the entire staff of the university becomes eligible for membership,
whatever the rank or job description.
Uh,
and
uh,
second,
the subway alumni are a very important part of any university,
right?
Like Notre Dame has a pot,
6 million subway alumni,
people who identify with the school and do all the stuff and never set foot on
an in the role of student.
Um,
and Yale has some of that to quite a lot of it.
So where do we go looking for people who obviously love the institution,
uh,
but don't,
don't show up on our record of alumni and such like a bar associations.
Say again,
like the parents of the students,
pair parents.
Uh,
yeah,
student parents are,
are one segment of subway alumni and we think we probably get four or 500 of
them to join,
uh,
annually.
And so that's,
that's not inconsequential.
Yeah.
University
donors.
Okay.
Anybody who has ever given a hundred bucks to Yale alumni or not a is clearly
eligible.
Anybody else you might think of?
Richard?
Yes.
Sporting events.
Yale's sporting events.
Very good.
And how would we,
how would we go about,
how would we go about finding the right list there?
Okay.
It's first of all a club,
you know,
we're not Joe's bar and grill,
so we can't sort of walk around at halftime at a football game with assigned,
come to Morrie's
affiliated with the university together.
Just kind of take it and get it for free.
He's,
and your student card or whatever it is,
you want to listen to the,
okay.
So we want actual paying customers and the,
the people we would aim at our tick season ticket holders,
right.
Season ticket holders for Yale athletics.
Okay.
There any other groups like that you might think of?
Let's talk about your parents and don't,
not about them being members of boys,
but what,
what would trigger them to be members of Morrie's if they lived near Yale and
we're not Yale alumnus.
Let me take a shot at that.
Not really.
Okay,
that's fine.
Where are we?
These Mbas?
No,
at all.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess,
uh,
as,
as parents coming to visit your student or your,
your son or daughter as a student,
um,
you may not necessarily be able to spend all the time that you're on campus with
them and you want somewhere you can go and that just kind of kill some time
while you're waiting.
Okay.
So that's the parent niche again.
How about people who have already shown a propensity to spend money in things
like Mars?
How about the membership roster of the new haven law and club?
How about the membership roster of the Quinnipiac Club where the graduates club
for the new haven country club or any one of 20 other comparable clubs in a 30
Mile Circle,
what do you think?
Who's got an intuition one way or the other about that?
Um,
let me,
let me give you another,
another,
another hint about that.
The dues at most of those clubs is measured in the low thousands per year.
The dues at Maury,
no one will pay more than a hundred dollars a year for Morrie's.
Okay.
I have pro.
And if you are a member of the log club,
the lawn club has food that is better than more,
each bought a hell of a lot worse than union league.
Okay.
And if I came to you and said a hundred bucks,
a hundred bucks,
2000 bucks,
100 bucks,
I might get you to switch clubs,
but more likely when I'd get you to do is to add Morrie's.
Um,
yes,
Jim
leaving out the all important a potential drinking business of the Grad and
professional students.
We are,
and I should point out to you the Jim Alexander,
whom you all know well,
not just from his Enron days,
uh,
is in eight days from now assuming office as President of Alon Club.
And I was talking about stealing his members,
sort of just to have fun with it.
And do you think he can keep that membership list secret from me?
I was president two years ago,
plus there's a membership directory that is published
now.
Would I want to harden the lung club?
Not at all,
but what I like to get in on the action.
Absolutely.
Now.
Uh,
yeah guys,
I have a question.
Does it follow this follow this line of sight?
So just a criticism I guess,
are you a bit concerned that if you open the net too broadly to Quinnipiac is to
Shane's yeah,
long club,
etc. That you may be diluting.
What was the value of the institution?
The first place,
which is what we mentioned before,
which is the history of being a Yale institution.
Okay.
Um,
that's a good question.
And uh,
let me,
let,
let's turn it,
let's go back to Jonathan and Chris about that.
If we let too many,
uh,
non blues in the door,
does the,
does the value of it for the Blues Begin to erode?
I don't think so.
Uh,
I don't think you can tell a yield graduate from a nine graduate,
frankly,
out in the general marketplace.
Uh,
I believe that the nature of Morrie's is going to be self selecting
people who are interested in do you want any,
um,
will will naturally go there.
Those who might not fit what you considered the mold or alluded that probably
would say you need.
Okay.
Um,
I actually think there is a little bit of a dilution problem and you know,
there's a little bit of a kind of Groucho Marx things thing.
We're just saying,
I don't want to be a member of a club.
They'll have me,
um,
the,
but the segment of students that we think we're going to get quite a great
change from that it started from zero is graduate and professional students.
Uh,
Leslie,
uh,
Leslie's a phd candidate in the political science department.
What are our prospects with you?
Well,
um,
I,
I'd say they're fairly good.
What we already pitched it to me as an upscale version of gypsy.
No,
the one,
one of the things,
how about Mbas?
I,
I'm hoping we're going to get about an 80% response rate from Mbas.
What do you think guys and what,
what is it and if you,
and other than trying to try this please me at the moment,
uh,
what are you going to get out of it?
Anybody?
Hey,
I think that for an Mba there's also a lot of benefit in the connections with
other alumni that are willing to pay and come back as far as networking and
future job opportunities and just getting to know people in specific areas.
Yep.
And one more,
and also I don't know of another place aside from Gypsy that has a patio where
we can just share a pitcher and,
um,
I think there's real value in just being able to have an anchor institution
that's close to the center of the university campus.
Absolutely.
Um,
so,
uh,
crash and we've got five minutes left and I'll actually
circle back to this later in the course.
But,
uh,
let's hear your pitch.
Chris is a born salesman.
Uh,
he is the best fundraiser I've ever been close to.
Um,
we've raised,
what was the number we determined this morning?
One point $7 million so far.
And uh,
Chris Pitch this thing.
Well,
I been pitch it to the students or today
pitch it,
pitch it general for what?
First of all,
as Doug said,
right now the food at Morrie's is worse than the lawn club.
I happened to be a longtime member of the lawn club and eat there,
ate there yesterday only because I couldn't go to Maurice.
But I think that in the future,
the food at Morrie's is going to,
this is our hope anyway,
the food and the service is going to be something that people will want to go
back to.
We had a lot of people who go there for the first time and say,
oh,
this is so cool because it is a unique place.
Blot their dining experience both food wise and service wise was,
was mediocre so they didn't become regular customers.
So our first hope is that all everybody and the bar in the back,
we think with the pub is going to be ideal for students and grownups for that
matter.
Uh,
and I just want add to what Doug was saying,
another couple of other groups that we're going to,
we're going to target our subscribers to the Yale Rep subscribers to the new
haven symphony orchestra subscribers,
delong or the Schubert.
We're people that we feel won't really dilute the character of the place.
Um,
man,
we were very optimistic that people are going to think that Morris is a good
value,
it's fun and uh,
they'll work.
They're going to want to go back there.
And we're very optimistic about this million nine in revenue.
I just,
I think that's a slam dunk.
Um,
and we'll be recruiting a marketing team,
uh,
in,
the spring term to help us,
uh,
hit the numbers we have to with a new student enrollments.
And I hope one or two of you will take an interest in that task.
And so it's actually a really interesting,
uh,
set of business problems.
Um,
first let's think my colleague
[inaudible]
on Monday.
Next,
please read the Goldman Sachs IPO,
which we'll take apart and we'll have the help of a Goldman partner while we do
it.